[Music]
as a sacrifice temple there's not a lot
of cities you can work this is one of
the only cities you know the problem is
a lot of these people already have
sacrificed temples they've been using
for years so to break into it at this
point is very hard job like you don't
remember me I remember you last July we
had a lot of fun come on he knows I'm
also trying to get into entertainment
I'm trying to do that has anybody else's
boss also killed themself a [ __ ]
weird you know listen I mean this is
like the next phase of my life I didn't
expect this to happen I thought I would
work until retirement but now I'm [ __ ]
you know I'm out here in LA trying to
break an entertainment this is my dream
even when Hillary Clinton was slicing
the throats of children I said I just
want to make people laugh my owner is
dead ish wherever he [ __ ] is it's not
using me anymore you know I was the
other day I was happiness for the
Scientology Celebrity Center and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] didn't even say hello
to me
[ __ ] You Know Who I am you [ __ ] Know
Who I am
I've had just as many celebrities inside
of me as you okay [ __ ] clown and
everybody thinks we're both [ __ ]
pervs and weirdos okay everybody it
wasn't always sacrifice sometimes it was
music night you know you think I control
what goes on no I get hired for job like
everybody else people do what they're
gonna [ __ ] do yeah I'm like a bouncy
castle for Satanic pedophiles you know
that's not only one of me finally just
got head shots meeting with a manager
don't know how it's gonna work don't
expect anything
somebody told me to start a podcast I
mean I guess it's not a bad idea but
this is where it's at now you know
carefully used to look at me used to say
one day I'm gonna be gone it shit's
gonna be different and you know what it
was [ __ ] right